on m'a dit que j'étais un enfant violent
que je pouvais faire du mal aux autres
il faut savoir rester à l'écart de la
famille d'éleveurs ça
vous aurez à faire un mois si vous vous
approcher trop près
les gens disent que les déverse son
dangereux répète un peu pour toi
moi je dis que chaque famille à son le
problème
je refuse que tu le vois
costes et toutes les choses que tu veux
on reste en alerte wired il me regarde
les yeux ouverts
n'était pas comme ça avant moi tu sais
avant de travailler pour ces [ __ ]
on a entendu parler de ce type on pense
qu'il est temps d'en finir avec lui il
faut qu'on le fasse
je crois loyal
[Musique]
une amortie
à partir d'ici
quelqu'un de dangereux